allez on continue à parler des éoliennes
en france avec un acteur majeur chez
nous ici c'est xavier barbaro pour newen
bonjour j'en avais un petit chèque
installez-vous 7 le pdg de neoen les
voix il faut expliquer un premier
producteur indépendant français
d'énergie 100 % renouvelable
trente trois parcs éoliens dans le monde
implantées essentiellement en australie
en finlande et en france qu'est ce que
vous faites concrètement sur un champ
d'éoliennes ou fabriquer les éoliennes
d'un spa ou de fabriquer les fait à peu
près tout le reste sir que nous on est à
l'origine du projet donc on va trouver
les terrains on obtient des permis fait
le montage industriel le montage
financier mais on sait d'où viennent
elles nous sont fournies par des acteurs
comme general electric vestas siemens
donc on les fait construire et ensuite
on les exploite voilà et les miles et
les pales qu'on voit tous ses produits
en france d'ailleurs alors plutôt en
europe il ya des composants français il
ya surtout des travaux d'ailleurs qui
sont fait évidemment par des entreprises
locales en mai ont globalement la france
et c'est une industrie européenne mais
qui est assez peu française pour la
partie visible après à nouveau le que ce
soit l'ingénierie ou la construction là
c'est très français et à qui elle est
revendue d'ailleurs après cette énergie
lait vendus à des entreprises des
particuliers pour l'instant en france
elle est mise dans le pot commun avec
edf qui agit comme chambre de
compensation serre que nous on envoie
des factures edf est ensuite edf envoie
ses électrons dans le réseau est
aujourd'hui cette électricité qui est
dans le pot commun elle est assez
compétitive et donc contrairement à
l'image d'épinal qui est resté
aujourd'hui l'éolien tire les prix vers
le bas qu'en france ça coûte combien de
produire d'électricité à base d'éolien
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de chiffres qui
circulent il yal'un telle est la
question d'intermittence la permanence
le fait qu'une éolienne ne tourne pas
toute la journée mais elle tourne quoi
25 30% du temps en fait elles tournent à
peu près tout le temps ah mais rarement
à pleine puissance donc taire quand on
veut résumer ça on dit qu'une éolienne
elle va tourner 20 ou 25% du temps donc
c'est parfait non c'est une autre
manière de le présenter c'est comme si
elle tournait 25% du temps à plein
régime en réalité elle tourne quasiment
100% du temps à 20 ou 30 ou 40% de son
maximum mais en fait c'est assez
homogène dans le temps et en plus comme
il ya en france plusieurs bassins devant
différents la production éolienne est
relativement régulière et d'en cas n'est
aujourd'hui plus compétitif cette
énergie éolienne énergie qui est moins
cher à produire et si on compare par
rapport ce n'est pas moi
au nucléaire qui est déjà amorti par
rapport au monde urbain à gaz quelques
repères aujourd'hui neoen et d'autres
acteurs en france à faire des électrons
éolien à peu près à 50 60 euros par
mégawattheure sas et nos unités de
compte mais pour les rendre plus
lisibles pour comparer à ce qui ce fait
d'autres aujourd'hui les marchés
d'électricité en france sont à peu près
à 200 voyez donc on est quasiment c'est
une situation qui est un pas normal
aussi voilà certes mais quand on regarde
le coût du nucléaire déjà amortis
aujourd'hui ses 46 euros et edf dit que
c'est pas assez vous voyez on est à peu
près nous avec d'une nouvelle éolien au
prix du nucléaire déjà amortis et quand
on regarde le nouveau nucléaire on a des
références par exemple les recteurs
produit construit par edf au royaume uni
c'est à peu près deux fois le prix de
l'éolien en france donc l'éolien
aujourd'hui c'est le prix de l'ancien
nucléaires déjà amortis et c'est la
moitié du prix du nouveau nucléaire
c'est important d'être capable de faire
de l'éolien en france parce qu'il ya un
gros potentiel il faut faire ça bien les
gens ont le droit d'être contre après il
faut pas non plus que les projets soient
bloqués parfois par une poignée
d'opposants il faut trouver un bon
équilibre entre ne pas faire n'importe
quoi ne pas aller planter des éoliennes
en face du mont saint-michel je pense
qu'on est tous d'accord ou presque tous
d'accord en tout cas nous on pense que
c'est une mauvaise idée est à l'envers
c'est pas parce qu'à en opposant qu'il
faut aussi s'interdire de faire un
projet après uniao yen qui fait la
taille de la tour montparnasse
comprenez que des riverains pour le coup
ne veulent pas sachant qu'elles peuvent
être à 500 mètres d'une dune d'une
habitation théorique c'est trop proche
évidemment et donc alors c'est assez
rare d'éoliennes qui font la taille de
la tour montparnasse était en bout de
pale ont donc le la partie le mort est
ce qu'on appelle la nacelle un qui est
la partie qui contient les équipements
électriques ça ça se situe à 80 90 100
120 mètres c'est déjà beaucoup comment
est ce qu'on fait pour que ces éoliennes
encore une fois que ces nuisances
sonores visuelles cette flamme une
grille afghane qui revient dans la part
des riverains lors que ce soit accepter
encore une fois où est ce que la réalité
c'est qu'en général ces paysages et
alors parfois le lait les gens utilisent
plusieurs arguments le gros sujet c'est
les questions de visibilité le bruit
objectivement il y en a quand même pas
beaucoup après il ya beaucoup de mythes
ce autour de l'éolien que ça émettrait
des infrasons des choses qui sont un peu
un peu virtuel mais ce qui est vrai
c'est que il ya des choses des règles
auxquelles on est soumis qui d'abord de
présenter notre projet de rencontre les
riverains de faire des séances publiques
nous on essaie d'aller au delà de ça
sert que parfois quand il ya dans un
projet éolien de neoen une éolienne ou
deux éoliennes qui font particulièrement
débat nous on s'est enlevé celles qui
font peut-être le plus de le plus de
problème donc voilà il ya une attitude
responsable pour un acteur comme nous
mais il y aura toujours des opposants et
il faut pas non plus écouté que les
opposants du fait des deux sets
intermittente cette paire mi-temps ce
qui existe avec les éoliennes il faut
parfois aussi s'appuyer sur des énergies
fossiles encore une fois qu'ils sont pas
propres comme le gaz est ce que c'est
pas un peu la limite aussi des éoliennes
actuellement puisqu'il faut un bac est
comment dire ouais je voudrais un peu
cassé quand même ce cette idée parce que
il ya un raccourci un peu facile qui est
dire il ya de l'hydraulique en france
qui est disponible dans des volumes
importants qui évidemment 100% verte
100% bleus moyens et qui serait au
service du nucléaire est par contre
l'intermittence du renouvelable que ce
soit l'éolien ou le solaire là il faudra
résoudre sans avec des avec des moyens
thermiques du gaz ou du diesel la
réalité c'est que il ya besoin d'avoir
des moyens flexible non seulement pour
l'intermittence du renouvelable mais
aussi pour
le contraire en fait qu'elle nucléaire
qui lui ne s'est jamais s'arrêter ou ne
sait jamais vraiment ce module et on a
besoin de flexibilité dans le système
cette flexibilité elle peut venir de
l'hydraulique l'hydraulique pourrait
tout aussi bien être au service du
renouvelable comme elle l'est
aujourd'hui aux services nucléaires la
flexibilité elle vient aussi d
interconnexion avec d'autres pays on
peut se passer des électrons d'un pays à
l'autre et plus la flexibilité
elle vient aussi de quelque chose qui
est nouveau et qui est très prometteur
qu'est la capacité de piloter un peu la
demande c'est-à-dire côté client côté
industriel côté résidentiel la capacité
à baisser si nécessaire un peu notre
consommation et donc à mieux vivre avec
l'intermittence du renouvelable quand
vous dites que c'est compétitif l'éolien
vous prenez en compte aussi le coût
complet sa bande le coût de stockage de
cette électricité ou pas alors à nouveau
il n'y a pas forcément besoin de la
stocker puisque le les bassins devant en
france on a cédé corrélés l'éolien quand
on regarde la production éolienne en
france elle est finalement restée
régulière elle n'est pas complètement
prêt serait des bassins certains bassins
compense d'autres vous avez la vallée du
rhône vous avez la bretagne vous et les
hauts de france tout ça tout ça
finalement
produit à des moments différents mais
mais ce lit ça c'est bien donc vous
n'avez pas forcément besoin de stocker
cette énergie sur le modèle économique
on a rien dit il ya beaucoup de dettes
j'imagine pour financer ses
infrastructures il ya des garanties de
prix avec l'état ces complexes ou pas
comme modèle économique le terme de
garantie est un peu trompeur au sens
l'état nous fait pas forcément une
faveur donc on a des contrats nous avec
l'état des contrats qui sont longs comme
ces contrats sont longs avec des
cash-flows garantie on peut assez
facilement se financer mais ces contrats
ils sont quand même dans l'intérêt des
deux parties c'est que nous on vend de
l'électricité de manière assez
prévisible et c'est très bien pour notre
capacité à nous financer mais
symétriquement les temps c'est qu'il va
pouvoir acheter l'électricité je vous le
disais à 60 euros par mégawatt heure
pendant 15 ans et c'est de la bonne
électricité verte et pas cher c'est une
pépite française née au n en finit là
dessus mais ils seront cadets beaucoup
de gens de l'énergie qui lorgne sur voie
gourmandise en pense évidemment total
énergie mais pas que vous avez les
moyens de financer votre croissance tout
en restant indépendant nous on a la
chance d'avoir un actionnariat qui est
stable qui est de qualité et qui capable
de réinvestir notre premier actionnaire
impala donc la société de jacques veyrat
et de sa famille à peu près 45 % du
capital de neoraine on a une société
aussi qui a comme actionnaire bpi france
le fsp dont des assureurs font donc la
question ne se pose pas à court terme
société qui est côté on a levé je
pénètre facilement n'insultons pas
l'avenir mais on a levé 600 millions
d'euros sur les marchés en 2021 la
demande était était vraiment là pour
participer à la croissance de neoraine
merci des barreaux merci david et bien
figurez vous que les éoliennes ne pousse
pas seulement dans les champs mais aussi
sur le toit des immeubles dans nos
villes
[Musique]